-With all the focus
on the midterms,
we haven't had enough time
to cover all the recent news,
so here with a recap is one of
our writers, Amber Ruffin,
in a segment we call
"Amber Says What."
♪♪♪♪
-You guys!
Things have been crazy!
Okay, first of all,
the President boarded a plane
with toilet paper on his shoe.
And I was like, "What?!"
Then he couldn't figure out
how to close his umbrella,
so he just left it
on the ground.
I was like, "What?!"
Then a dating website for
people who love Trump came out
called Donald Daters.
I saw that,
and I was like, "Gross."
Then everybody was like,
"Kendall Jenner culturally
appropriated an afro."
And I was like,
"What...are you talking about?"
[ Australian accent ]
That's not an afro.
This is an afro!
[ Normal voice ]
And then people were like,
"Stop talking like that,"
and I was like, "Yeah."
But, really,
that's not an afro.
That's a white girl who slept
at her boyfriend's house
and had to use man shampoo.
Then people were mad
about a Martin Luther King
statue in Buffalo
because they said it looks
nothing like Martin Luther King.
And I was like,
"How bad could it be?"
But then I saw the picture
and was like...
[Laughing] "What?"
What?! That guy looks nothing
like Martin Luther King.
You know who looks more like
Martin Luther King?
This guy.
Then Oprah canvassed
for Stacey Abrams in Georgia,
and I was like, "What?!"
Can you imagine having Oprah
come to your door?
It'd be like,
"What? Is this your house?
Do you want my house?
I'm sorry.
I shouldn't have been in here.
Come on, children.
This is Oprah's house now."
Then at a Republican rally,
someone from Trump's cabinet
described Florida's
governor election as
"cotton-pickin' important."
I heard that and was like...
[ To tune of "Dixie" ]
Wh-wh-wh-what, wh-wh-wh-what?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, you know
what happened today?
Idris Elba was named "People"
Magazine's Sexiest Man Alive.
And I was like,
"Why does that sound familiar?"
Oh, yeah. Here's why.
Blake Shelton was named
Sexiest Man Alive,
and I was like, "What...
happened to Idris Elba?
Is he okay?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right! I called it!
And I'm calling next year's
Sexiest Man Alive.
Idris Elba.
And the year after that,
And so on and so forth
until he dies,
at which point he will be
Sexiest Ghost Alive.
In other news, there is a
Mandarin duck in Central Park,
and everybody is freaking out
because it came from China and
no one knows how it got here.
But it is the most beautiful
bird I have ever seen.
I saw that Chinese duck,
and I was like...
Back here in America,
white ladies have been
calling the cops on black people
for the stupidest reasons.
She called 911 on a black man
who was planting
a community garden.
She called the cops
on a black guy
who was entering
his own apartment.
And she called him
on a 9-year-old child
for just living.
I read all that and was like
"Well, surely, this can't
get any more ridiculous."
And that's when it happened.
White people who were on a boat
called the police on a whale!
Look!
-It's fine. It's fine.
It's right under us.
-Um, I'm out in Puget Sound,
and there's three whales
right underneath our boat,
and I'm afraid that
we might get flipped over.
-Drive away.
[ Laughter ]
-I saw that
and was like, "What?"
You can't call the cops on a
whale when you're in the ocean.
You're in his house.
He should call the police
on you.
Now, don't get me wrong.
If you come downstairs and
see a whale out your window,
please call the police.
And finally, it is the end
of a very long Election Day.
So, to Democrats,
I just want to say,
you campaigned hard,
you registered
thousands of new voters,
and you had a lot
of firsts tonight.
First openly gay male governor
in history. What?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Massachusetts' first black
Congresswoman. What?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Connecticut's first black
Congresswoman. What?!
The youngest
Congresswoman ever! What?!
Texas' first two Latina
Congresswomen. What, what?!
And the first two Muslim
and the first two Native
American Congresswomen.
What, what, what, what?!
Yeah!
And to Republicans,
I just want to say, "What?"
This has been "Amber Says What."